hey and speaking of this week in nascar
the big weekend channel 8 will bring you
the most complete coverage of all your
nascar ron futrell has camped out at the
las vegas motor speedway through sunday
and
hey ron when they use the word camp do
we mean a 41 foot state-of-the-art rv
is that where you're sitting around the
campfire tonight enjoying that
i am not i am not roughing it tonight
but i do have to tell you sort of
interesting i didn't realize nellis
flies jets till nine o'clock at night i
know a lot of people from north las
vegas have known that for years but now
that i live in the neighborhood i'm
finding that out okay this is a fifth
wheel so this what happens here this
thing hooks into the back of a big truck
to be able to tow this thing like you
said 41 feet long we took a little tour
of it today at johnny walker rv so that
i i learned my way around oh it has all
the amenities
this has just about everything you could
possibly imagine inside a big wheel and
the general manager ronnie told me a
little bit about what i can expect in
this big rig
this is your kitchenette area right you
have your recliners over on this side
have your island for cooking plenty of
counter space
entertainment wise you got the same tv
that you have at your house smart tv
jbl sound system in there with a
subwoofer so if you really want to get
get it rocking we have an electric
fireplace down here i mean it really
gives all the amenities at home
of course it has an electric fireplace
so i might turn it up a little bit
tonight as it's getting a little cool
out here it's quiet right now at the
speedway it's going to be cranking up
tomorrow and of course throughout the
weekend as we continue our our coverage
out here i'll be back live at six
o'clock in the morning if anybody's
staying up late tonight cares too cares
to watch in the morning but coming to
you live from the casa de ronandoa ron
futrell live local now